we're asked to subtract and we have the
complex number 2 minus 3i and from that
we are subtracting 6 minus 18i so the
first thing I'd like to do here is to
just kind of get rid of these
parentheses so we just have a bunch of
real parts and imaginary parts that we
can then add up together so we have 2
minus 3i and then we're subtracting this
entire quantity and to get rid of the
parentheses we can just distribute the
negative sign or another way to think
about it we can say that this is
negative 1 times all of this so we can
just distribute the negative sign a
negative 1 times 6 is negative 6 let me
do these in magenta so this is negative
6 and the negative 1 times negative 18i
well that's just going to be positive
positive 89 egative times a negative is
a positive and now we want to add the
real parts and we want to add the
imaginary parts so here's a real part
here 2 and then we have a minus 6 so we
have 2 minus 6 and we want to add the
imaginary parts we have a negative let
me do that in a different color we have
a negative 3i right over here so
negative 3i or minus 3i right over there
and then we have a plus 18 I or positive
18 I so then we have a positive 18 I if
you add the real parts 2 minus 6 is
negative 4 and you imagine add the add
the imaginary parts if I have negative 3
of something and to that I add 18 of
something well that's just going to
leave me with 15 of that something or
another way you could think about if I
have 18 of something and I subtract 3 of
that something I'll have 15 of that
something and in this case the something
is the ahmet is i is the imaginary unit
so this is so this is going to be plus
15 plus 15 i and we are done